we're here at the vanity fair oscars
party are you excited have you is this a
party you love every year i'm excited
i've been coming to this party for many
years i always meet a lot of people that
uh i'm a fan of and who are my heroes so
look forward to that how did you feel
about the show tonight
i thought it was one of the best shows
it was most exciting
fun
best representation
funny as hell and then there's an
unfortunate incident
but i thought i killed
uh the unfortunate incident let's
discuss it what was your reaction
it was like at first you thought oh my
god it's a skit oh my god just wait a
minute there's no punch line wait whoa
it's a punch not a punch line
and you're like oh that's that's really
unfortunate and how did you feel about
will's speech
you know
i would like the more of a straight
apology
to chris you know
that would have been that would have
been great because i mean i thought
will's performance was amazing and i'm
sorry that he
tarnished it with this behavior you know
i mean we all nobody likes to be made
fun of but you got to have a sense of
humor about yourself can't take yourself
that seriously i mean we're just acting
you know let's just relax
do you what do you think the academy
does from here
i don't know that's gonna be interesting
i mean it's gonna be interesting i mean
he said in his speech i hope i'm allowed
to come back i don't know
well you're somebody who's been in this
business for a long time so i wanted
your thoughts on it because you know
what it's like to be in the headlines to
yeah to do all that yeah we all get
hot-headed we all get excited you know
we all take ourselves a little too
seriously but there's a lesson to be
learned for all of us you know
everything is a learned learning
opportunity a life lesson
well it's been an exciting year for you
what's been a highlight
oh well the bruno song i mean
who would have thought that it would
become a worldwide phenomenon it's
insane bigger than frozen
bigger than frozen bigger than almost
anything it's like platinum
uh
five five weeks number one on billboard
number one on spotify people like acting
it out it's gonna be a halloween thing
the performance tonight megan the
stallion
oh that was oh that was that was
everything
tell me what you thought she did my rap
she did i mean way better than i could
ever do it i mean they should have hired
her not me
did you know that was gonna happen no no
i was totally surprised no because i
when i when i did my rehearsal they did
their rehearsal at a different time so i
didn't see the performance oh my god
yeah yeah what's your reaction in the
room oh it was it was i thought it it
stole the show i thought it was the best
performance of the night and we missed
lin manuel he had the covet scare me
yeah yeah cause he's talking to egot
it was so close you know the youngest he
got in the world but you know
have you talked to him
we texted yeah he was always said it's
unfortunate that he's not didn't make it
but he's proud of everybody he we're
there because of him he's our cultural
hero you know he's a cultural genius for
us latinx and i guess for the world as
well completely i hope would you guys
work together again oh i hope so
i'll keep my keep my phone clear
yeah if lin-manuel's calling um well
what do you think you had a bigger
reaction to megan the stallion or tell
me your your just genuine reaction in
the moment to the will smith chris rock
of it all in the room
nobody knew what was going on the thing
honestly nobody knew what was happening
you're just like oh it's a skit oh it's
going to be real funny oh
it's not funny is there is there a punch
no you so you don't you didn't know
until after the fact when he started
you know saying
when he told him don't talk about my
wife then you're like oh okay this is
for real this is beef and is that just
silence
yeah and then nobody else you know
anthony hopkins came up afterwards
and he didn't know how to respond to it
so nobody else commented on it and let
it go so okay we were all kind of
watching the show like okay it's just
still somebody's got to comment on it
but nobody did but we were coming on it
behind behind the scenes you're all
talking about it
oh really what were people saying it's
like what happened why why that why you
know it's just a joke
just take it as a joke just chill